bullying ideas YouTube intro hello and
welcome to the folding ideas YouTube
channel here you're going to find three
main kinds of content first are the
full-length episodes these range between
15 and 30 minutes long and consist of an
in-depth contextual analysis of a
specific subject be it a movie or a
television show or a social movement
second are the minisodes these tend to
be 2 to 5 minutes long and cover things
like jargon questions for viewers and
follow-ups to previous episodes third
are highlights from live streams which
they're highlights from from the live
streams so that's where you can expect
to find here on the channel I am most
active on twitter you can follow me
there at foldable human I also have an
ask fm page and we're technically on
Facebook you know what you're supposed
to say when you go out of these is like
like share subscribe like share
subscribe like share subscribe light
light light light share subscribe like
like share subscribe like